hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
once again we are looking at Easter eggs
and cultural references and the occasion
would mean to found unfortunate Battle
Royale today it's all about season 3
which ran from February 22nd through to
April the 30 of 2018 if you've missed
our breakdown of season 1 & 2 I'll be
sure to link them at the end of the
video anyways sit back and relax and
let's go through as many as we can the
rest lot became available during season
3 his look and named Bruce Lord are
obviously nod to the guardians of the
galaxy and the character Peter quill aka
star-lord Oh also have you noticed he
wears a pin badge with a familiar you
design this is the logo of the Unreal
Engine which powers hundreds upon
thousands of video games such as player
unknowns battlegrounds and even rocket
League and you've guessed it it was
created and maintained by Epic Games the
creator behind fortnight battle royale
the Reaper skin made its debut in season
3 and was quickly renamed John wick this
is because the character is the spitting
image of actor Keanu Reeves who plays
John wick in the John wick films did I
say John wick enough times in that
sentence the John wick references
continue with the glider unlocked after
tier 100 of the battle pass and the
resemblance to John's favorite car in
the movie series there's even a pickaxe
dedicated to wick and his pencil killing
legend banjo do you remember the vine
revolution back in 2012
well vine introduced us to many viral
stars one of which Milan web became a
sensation with his watermelone gags but
his best mate dance transcended the vine
platform and is now immortalized in
fortnight Battle Royale
sidetrack there's a literal Easter egg
in fortnight which can be strapped to
your back no less this is called
hard-boiled which also could be a
reference to the film of the same name
in which an undercover cop takes down
triads he ends up killing 99 gang
members 1 vs. 99 that definitely rings a
bell did you ever see the viral video of
a guy at the beach trying to get the
attention of a lovely lady I'm not sure
about her but I was dumb impressed and
where that's where the flippin sexy
emote originates I recommend not trying
this on a concrete floor but make it
rain emote is literally a reference to
throwing dollar bills at strippers in a
club I had to do a great deal of
research to confirm that suspicion I
digress
I did find that this music video from
back in 2006 from Fat Joe and little
Wayne which brought the term into
popular culture and shows the emote in
action he makes it rain on those hosts
it sounds delightful doesn't it what's
up for tonight community another twitch
streamer was honored during season 3 CD
and the third is known for his push for
positivity in his chats with this symbol
depicting the positive energy his
viewers hold when the emote made it into
the game this was his reaction look what
it says Riya read it oh my god
positivity have a phenomenal gaming
experience
dance emotes were scattered through
season 3 both in the battle past and
through the marketplace they take the el
dance emote was based on the 2017 remake
of the horror film it and his pretty
awesome dance moves comedies were also
referenced through dance with the
hootenanny
originating in 1994 Dumb and Dumber
movie all we need now is that orange
suit I don't know about you but I use
the jubilations emote to confuse the
hell up to the enemy with footsteps but
it actually originates from the comedy
series Seinfeld back
the 1980s and 90s the reanimated emote
blends the iconic thriller dance from
the King of Pop Michael Jackson but
infuses it with a modern dance craze
from Japan and Korea complete with
ridiculous care alarms I'm already
certain you know the origins of the
disco fever emo but just in case you
don't it was made iconic by the film
Saturday Night Fever starring John
Travolta ask your mother about him
she'll definitely know speaking of the
disco era the funk op skin hops back to
the 1970s also but in addition he looks
very much like eddie gordo from tekken 3
and his alter-ego tiger
the breaking point emote which allows us
to threaten our enemies is a trope from
nineteen eighties action films in
particular jean-claude Van Damme movies
such as kickboxer and blood-spot it
depicts the enemy being overly arrogant
and usually they are defeated soon after
point proven
another Van Damme reference popped up at
the end of season three through the
steel sight skin which borrows heavily
from the Universal Soldier movie from
back in 1992 in this one Van Damme
became a cyborg soldier the 90s were so
[ __ ] good another John Travolta
reference this time from the film Pulp
Fiction can be found in the confused
emote in the film he's trying to figure
out how intercoms work but actually
became a huge meme which was impossible
to ignore when the Leviathan skin
released the armor looks mighty familiar
I believe this is a reference to destiny
- and the raid which so happens to be
called the Leviathan the white and gold
leaf armor were rewards for completing
this activity the wiggly mode it can't
be a reference to anything can it well
well yes it is in actuality it's a nod
to the French player brokey brach sorry
for saying that completely wrong who
formerly played call of duty at pro
level before jumping over to fortnight
pretty cool though
once again epic games are saluting their
community many people believe the
burnout skin is in honor of twitch
streamer doctor disrespect but I'm not
so sure
instead I believe the costume consisting
of a biker jacket and red cravat is a
reference to negan from the walking dead
I'm not certain about this one though
what do you guys think something simply
awesome now a great way to invite your
girl to prom in the house to the right
of greasy Grove just at the top of the
stairs is a note grab a sniper and zoom
in and you can read this Andrea
will you go to prom with me Eric I do
hope she said yes
another emote snuck into season 3 in the
last
the tide emote is a nod to Snoop Dogg
and the song drop it like a taco before
I go I have to talk about the build-up
to season four from April the 18th and
meteor was spotted in the sky which grew
each day by aiming at the rock a subtle
sound could be heard well some clever
people broke down the sound and found it
was probably take the le molt it goes
further though if you use the controller
with a rumble option switched on you
would feel a rumble at certain areas of
the map using a grid system players
discovered that the vibrations once
again used Morse code and made up the
following SOS d5 418 SOS is the
international code for distress d5 is
where Tilted towers is situated and 418
could represent April 2018 or week on
from this and the island began beaming
out test signals to all the televisions
again better minds and I deciphered the
code which read they don't want us to
know and then it just cuts off the
following day signs on top of the
buildings in tilted towers look to be
welcoming alien visitors in a homage to
Independence Day and we all know how
that went in the movie
that's the end of season 3 though so
I'll stop right here but rest assured
I'll be back on the final day of season
4 to look at all the new Easter eggs and
references included in fortnight Battle
Royale who've this has been an epic
undertaking I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade it's been a pleasure as always
I'll see you next time
[Music]